こんにちははじめ雪をです
俺は今
[音楽]
猛烈に怒っています久しぶりにちょっとこうカチンときたことがありまして
ちょっとそれを今日は皆さんにお話しさせていただこうと思います珍しいですよ
普段あんなに横行で優しいと言われている肇社長が起こるってよっぽどのことですから
ねぇ
ああああああ
ビジュルザネザー
オーラ elsa ねぇ許しますけど許しますけども連れても許せなかったのね
ちょっと今回はそいつについて強化楽しんでいただこうと思います結構近場で起きた
ことなんですけどもあの僕よく行くめちゃくちゃ近くにコンビニがあるんですよ
めちゃくちゃいでぼくよくそのコンビに使わせていただくんですけれどもやっぱりその
何度も何度も毎日毎日っていると店員さん
とちょっとなんかまあ仲良くなってるだけじゃないんですよ無事そんな僕ならなレート
を下げないですしね
全然だレートがしたくないんですけどまぁそれに花王でば覚えてくるわけですぼくも
ああいうテリーさんがいることはーいうお客さんがよくくれても分かってきてるんです
けど僕のそんな全然政権前の日とかしたい方じゃないんですよ
よく使うからこそあんまりそういう話
したがないというかデータ度客との関係それ以上なフェス現場だとかもしたいような
関係性を築きたくないと思っておりまして何か話しかけられても俺は教員天気ですねて
きてもそうですねじゃあ感じと冷たい感じがするんで申し訳ないんですけどあんまり
その距離感を詰めなくない距離感でずっと言いたいタイプのケインさんとお客さんの
状態
を保ちたかったんですけどデータというのはちょっと主婦の方というか
女性の方なんです
けどもねなる日突然今まで全然そういう会話した方がなかったのにあの娘がちょっと山
で娘がファンでよかったサイン
いただけますでそうかみたいなことを言われたんですよ
まぁまぁそれでもその人の子供が喜ぶはずであったら僕も喜んで就きたいと思って書い
たんですよ
まあこれ全然後悔いいですよぜひ良いです部活で全然いいと思うんですよ
まあお店からしたら頭が知りませんけどねお店からしたら金を頂いている業務つにそう
いうことしていいのかどうかっていうのは会社的にインしたら僕でいいかわかんない
ですけど僕はでですが書きますといいんですよって言ってこれって米自宅でさに書かせ
ていただいたんですけどもまぁそれもいいでしょ
いいですここも全然いいですむしろ ok いい人だと思いました
コングラチュレーションでございます
ああああああ
だそこで話が終わっちゃう俺はこんなに怒っちゃいねえ
そこからだ他の人もなかっ
私もいいですかみたいなその私も西村 ds 鑑定な感じです本尊のキャブん
レーサーのみたいなお守りだしてきて他の方にお子がさの定義さなのに社員良くなる
ことが増えまして
まあ
いいですよまあいいです純朴にかけます前で書きます
むしろいつもコンビでお世話になってるんでそれぐらいのことされていただきたいと
いう気持ちは
まあないこともなかったんで前で限らせてわけで書きますけども
そっからそっからがちょっ超僕が勝つにときましたねさしぶりにまあすごい人相談で
直接本人には言わないんでこういう場でもう言わせリーダーくんですけど
メンター船って凍っとても言えないですいいとだぜなんで課題て心の組んでしまって
おくのもちょっとモヤモヤして嫌だなと思ったんで今回ここで言わせていただいてるん
ですけどまぁ花はない言葉にサイン書いた女性の方にか
んねか曽根田1週間後がわからないですけど時間ないで急いでてお昼ご飯でまたまた
探しているんですけどそこに打って切って
あーをすいません
あのサインもう2枚だけもらってもいいですか
ずっと待ってくれ商材ん
誰で渡瀬のあなたの周りの人のサイン何でも書くと思って登って僕だったら思います
けどねで筆記具人のちょっと急い前後にレジで iphone のした後に3枚
色紙に書かされて一番はそのパターンがあったんですよちゃんと誰かにわたっているの
はたったんですけどもう自慢に関してはああっあっ
名前買っていいですみたいな
はぁはぁもう待ってははたグッド galil から美味しいし書いてんじゃないの
渡津人がいないように式消火具意味
何思うですねそれ聞いた瞬間めっちゃ仲良いだとして何では立つ人いないのにし気性で
書いていることと思いますが誰かにあげたいカラス地下化されていると思ってるわけ
でしょ
名前ないんだったらストップようでなんか誰者20人社長にサインもらったよあげる
みたいなかターン日目リカでとかでなんかそういうなんかオークションなどで転売する
かの2体の4カ国で見えなくなって
どのお姉さんが俺すごいなるフォアが感じましたねを見せて働いている人としておいの
何度も何度するのは僕はよくないと思います
素直にお店からすると音なんなのいいよ別に言われ赤くよ俺裁断内でもさぁ時間後は
書かないんですけどサインペンで書くけどさぁ
名前だしていいでどういうことストーン
ぐざふターン全敗したいのいっぱいそれが誰かに飯共済カラット来た俺の3位
そういうふうに俺は思ったねあーもうこういうこと言うからまずはコンビニにも行けず
だけたらしいまあいいんですけど
ただ俺はちょいとた2の寒行潰したくないんで本人に面と向かって言わないんですよ
ここで様子でいただいてるだけですよなあこっちへてしないでください
ああああああっ
ああああああ
いやそういうのじゃないんですよそういうのじゃないってああ
そういうのですけど絵草紙てくれるんだよあ見分けるは変わっちゃうがパワーを急いだ
からお前辺でもいいから今どこになったんだぞこれ
次だよわぁ終わっ緒絶叫んで惚れざる
対する意見であった
ああああああ
ザー
[音楽]
おりゃ比べ俺は2位は各や作業を持つの時間になれば全然苦けども
時間がないときやっぱりも書けねえんだを欄を他の皆と来てるわけだ私が書くことでと
参与角度待っている仲間っての時間のことを考えてってこそそして何度も何度もさんに
求めてくる奴はまずでよくわかって各本人に再方が全然いいんだけども
その本人
鳴らし槍とかのたくさん絵画化されればホラー許せで間接的におらアサリを渡したく
ねぇ
ましてとどっかに書いたところにあっ名前はいいですよ名前なしでか山でとなんか
10倍とかメディカリーダーパワーネットでオーラーまずなーって言ってねそれではで
は
どうか着替えていただけるととてもありがたいと思っておりますすみませんよろしくお
願い致しますせーのかめはめ波
[音楽]
[拍手]